what is bioinformatics
is the development implementation and use
of software methods and tools to
understand biological data
bioinformatics has
practical applications in health agriculture and
climate change mitigation
as this field advances bioinformatics
presents several challenges for both
students trying to  learning it as well as
for teachers trying to
teach it
in this presentation i will
explain the current challenges and
limitations of
bioinformatics i will
describe how we intend to address
these challenges with the homex logic platform i will
describe bloom's taxonomy and
how it can be used in bioinformatics courses will
explore the  homex logic program and how do you
use the blog taxonomy to
structure your course lines and projects and
finally describe various results
of the homex logic program
so what are some of the
challenges currently facing the
field of bioinformatics to start
this ca  mpo is constantly growing
and developing new technologies and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets analyzed are
often very large and consume immense
amounts of computing power and
memory that many computers do not
have
and furthermore despite being
Publicly available data is also
often complex to access and often
requires programming knowledge
to do so Likewise, pipelines and
analytics programs require
programming knowledge
that many biologists lack in a
university environment Students
have the opportunity to learn the
basic information to design and
implement a
bioinformatics project but do not receive
hands-on experience with the full workflow
due to the aforementioned limitations
similarly
teachers face challenges in being able to
cover a wide range of topics if they
specialize in one area  a particular
bioinformatics or are not familiar
with bioinformatics in general for
example a professor whose
research focuses on
oncogene expression may not know much about
marine metagenomics to overcome these
challenges the homex logic platform was developed
this program
aims  standardize organize and
systematize information in
bioinformatics so that these analyzes
are useful to any
clinical biologist some
standardization issues materials for such
courses are often developed in-
house taught sporadically
and rarely updated
organization because the challenge is to
combine various topics  different
and develop flow and
transitions
systematization how can you know
someone is working and needs help
or allow someone to go ahead
homex logic uses
standardized models of interactive sessions
that begin with mastery of
terminology  and the concepts to
implement these concepts with
real data sets in a
project-based approach
learning process to create a
clear skill development path
or mick lo as they employ
blunk's taxonomy learning levels this
approach starts a basic color
students remember facts and
terminology and can repeat and
memorize material on this basis
learning builds
conceptual knowledge be able to comprehend
concepts and apply information to new
situations the student will be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and talking
when using certain methods this
leads them to higher  level of learning
the ability to design and create original works
then like them in
homex logic resources to advance bioinformatics education
or exclude me which is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics made up of courses
designed to guide you to  through
knowledge  Theoretical nt homex which
combine training modules on
data anal tools
data sets from selected projects and
interactive tutorial sessions to
provide the student with a clear
path through the blog taxonomy
regardless of
initial user experience with the computer pathway
homex logic is a useful tool for
gaining a basic understanding of the
theory behind bioinformatics
analyzing large data sets an
introduction to
basic coding languages ​​such as
and payton or starting a
data analysis project
these six courses are taken from the curriculum
homex logic basic studies
available online
beginning with introduction to
bioinformatics applications and an
overview of data types
the student can learn the
terminology and practical knowledge
to build on from there
genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics are introduced  epi
gene  omics and data science each
course begins with key terms and concepts
then introduces home studies and
projects related to each this
allows students to gain
the conceptual knowledge to
start their own projects
expanding the core curriculum
with projects the methods  good form
ticos are best learned in context
real case studies
prepared by our network of mentors and
collaborators illustrating how
various methods are used but
unique informatics and data types
current research in medicine
biotechnology
agriculture including astrobiology
projects are prepared by taking sets
of publicly available data and
using it to explore and understand
the research challenge of the
analysis path to extract
meaningful insights from complex unique data
for the homex logic platform
provides students with options for analyzing
a given data set  these
datasets and associated publications
can be used in various ways you can
learn bioinformatics without
any coding for in each project we
explain the lines of analysis
of bio info's friendly platform
for big data analysis you can also
learn the scripts behind many
from pastures learning to organize
clean visualize analyze data in
popular languages ​​like er and payton
to create your own analyzes you
can finally learn about the projects and
their research applications in
our mentor-led programs
where experts
share their experiences
and support research projects
that you develop
this is an example of a
standalone programming
pipeline the pipeline builder interface in the
bio info platform is a
color-coded pipeline that helps
make a logical connection between the
technical names
of data analysis methods and the  p  logical steps
needed to build the
complete pipeline data is entered as an
input file and then analyzes can be
chosen based on the type of
survey each analysis is separated into three
colors blue for pre-processing red
for mapping and green for quantification
each time  click a button a
popup window will contain
additional information useful for building the
pipeline the ease of
color-coded buttons allows
programs to be run without any
programming knowledge
after using the platform should have
focused on visualizing pipelines and
practicing analysis on  students
can take their theoretical knowledge
remember to understand bloom levels
and apply it to the project apply
analyze and evaluate bloom levels in
the same way teachers should be
able to assign the program or mick logic to
their students with the understanding that
it will give them holistic knowledge  and
completed  or bioinformatics starting
with bytes and molecules and designing your
own design based on questions
another goal of the project is for
students to be able to read
primary literature and understand and
recreate the methodology
this leads to the ability to find
errors apply theoretical knowledge
of why
mistakes happen and find a solution
o mick logic employs a fried approach
combining learning and inquiry
to ensure students
develop the first level of the
bloom taxonomy o mix
logic tracks progress with
activities such as coding pipelines
and review reviews  literature quizzes
on topics key terms and
important questions and covers a wide range of
topics such as biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
then students can continue
their knowledge base with
research assessment making
sure they can understand the methods the
challenges and l  results as well as being
able to understand the
primary research literature
should also be able to ask questions based
on data exploration the informatics pathway
combines
life
science terms with data science skills allowing
researchers to answer questions
deschiens es  of life with
reproducible
data analysis methods Homex Logic Research Fellows
can ask
research questions on any
bioinformatics topic leading to a wide
range of projects from analyzing
biological pathways affected in
multiple sclerosis to
brain metastases due to
small cell lung cancer
these students can apply what they have
learned in the course worked with a
group of professional mentors and submit
their projects to the portal for review
and then students should be able to
reach the highest level of the
taxonomy should  create this I know  gre
creating her own analysis project
for example laura garcía developed a
project in this project a
random forest classifier was proposed to
discriminate bacteriocins from
antibiotics and non-antibiotics
based on amino acid composition
another example was the
income project to whom she shared her
presentation of a
research project developed in this
research grant program he does
not exclude me that focused on the analysis they
created transcriptomics of the progression
of the disease and the pathogenesis of t and
alzheimer's disease
his project gave him great prominence
since he obtained the first  place in the
mexican science cup for what
represented the country internationally
lastly the squid and
mayoral penya project that aims to
develop an algorithm for the
prediction of membrane biomarkers
in triple negative breast cancer cells
from
transcript analysis micos and for him  the great
result was to introduce
bioinformatics to those who don't know and the
great advantage was
the software that works
intuitively homex logic is proud to
collaborate with many programs for
example
night and i give this national
leading researchers of ideas
we also work  With more than 15,000
students in community colleges such
as the Community College Plan, the
best universities such as
Georgetown University, as well as 20
universities around the world.